foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
my God
[Music]
good morning
good morning everybody
[Music]
one second you are on time today of
course sub you're always on time
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
myself in good God
is it so freaking hard
yeah this game's really really really
hard
foreign
for sure
I don't think anyone's denying that
good morning Flanders Ben pumps
hello
how we doing today fellas
we got the webcam back on
the camera
I bought it today and I'm stuck on the
first boss
what he's struggling with what's wrong
yes it is the afternoon in the
Netherlands hello Netherlands I want to
visit the Netherlands
I really do
I want to go to Europe somewhere I've
never been outside of the U.S before
I forgot we had this in Japanese dude
what up pastor
[Music]
did I I heard Amsterdam's really nice
yeah
but it's really expensive
that's what I keep hearing
[Music]
Italy
I don't know I'll go anywhere I gotta
check it all out you know what I'm
saying
I feel like bloodborne was harder
I don't know man
I think learning this game is probably
harder
so I gotta jump off here right yeah
terrifying terrifying
yeet
nice
got a little scratch in my throat today
that's kind of worrying me a little bit
we're gonna be fine
we're gonna live
so much Ash
what the
SE guys remind me of the stone dudes in
the
the dungeons
holy [ __ ] he's alive again
nope
I'm just not [ __ ] around with that
that's some type of weird zombie
I want anything to do with that
once you learn the patterns bloodborne
said [ __ ] the patterns there's patterns
in bloodborne isn't there
I think there is
sakuro charmless demon Bell should we
try that someday
sorry dudes I'm trying to get this
scratch out of my throat
it's no fun
you got a death blow them twice
is there only one of those guys
oh there's a boss right there like right
over my head
I find these guys to be a major pain in
the ass
I'm gonna go over here real quick though
or
this game's like learning an instrument
don't you think any games like that
like whenever you pick up a game for the
first time it's always going to be hard
right
I think so
do I have to get both of these to get
this because we definitely want Breath
of Life
I think I do okay now it's open and we
need five skill points got it
Gothenburg
honestly sounds like something out of
bloodborne
I need to stop playing these games so
much
they're all I think about
apparently
[ __ ] I hate this
[Music]
there we go
that's good to hear Austin
oh okay this is a big gun guy no this is
the boss
he ran all the way over here
yep
get out of here
nope
[Music]
thank you
these are my least favorite guys to
fight in this game
straight up
okay let's get out of this tent
I'm not about the tents
[Music]
uh my dog will come down here if she
wants to calm down thank you
nice
okay and that's all it takes guys
foreign
to just get annihilated and die oh
through the wall
she really doesn't want to leave this
area
okay
come come
foreign
oh God
foreign
[Music]
no shot
the worst timing possible
we're gonna take out this other guy
she got me
oh [ __ ]
I don't have heels
scratch that
[Music]
thank you
this [ __ ] game dude
this [ __ ] game
could still shoot
as I each imanji you
I got stuck in the
you
dude it's amazing when there's like more
than one character that you have to
fight in this game
it's so incredibly hard when it's not a
character that you can just kill in like
two hits or whatever
right
[Music]
like this guy not so bad these guys not
so bad
well I died
one time so far Joe
okay where's the other guy
over here looking at me we're gonna go
this way
kill this guy to make me feel better
excellent
I have thought well I'm fighting a boss
right now
okay
okay
[ __ ]
you're damn right I put Pro Gamer in the
title you kidding me
[Music]
that's what I am bro
I'm not really showing it right now
this couldn't be a worse [ __ ] combat
a worse thing to have in combat is this
guy
he takes a bunch of hits to kill almost
like a boss
this is not going well
[Music]
oh my God
I don't know what to do
I can't get this guy by himself
shoes are off
eating grapes
calming down
good start
I really don't use sugars that much
I probably should
probably should
[Music]
just gotta calm down boys just gotta
calm down
I'm just gonna go for the boss I think
we got majorly unlucky
with the other guy coming to fight I
think that was just really unlucky
quick backstab go over here now
you're easy by yourself
you really are
as I say that gets hit by everything
[Music]
come come
perfect couldn't be better
oh that was bad
okay I thought she'd shoot there
she did not
this wall is not doing us any favors
nerd
Pro Gamer
not so hard when you're by yourself just
saying
you're kind of a pushover
and then uh
Miyazaki hears that
would you say God skin Duo
creates God's skin Duo
okay sorry
hey it's the guy
the crazy guy
more grapes
double eight fight is not that bad it's
okay it's hard for sure
[Music]
grapes
eyeballs
what up Trey foreign
by a girl he's basically a simp
pretty much what's happening
a ghostly woman is taking over his mind
yeah God's can do it well actually it's
God skin Duo really that hard anymore
now that you can uh
sleep them everyone knows he can just
use sleeping stuff
you know
isn't this area the one with the the
boss that's like a complete pushover
like it's not even a boss
oh that's an item
oh yeah it is still hard
foreign
for sure
okay they all need to chill down there
they're being just fine away from me
hello
hi Kristoff
thank you
there you go fiction yeah summons make
it a lot easier too
missed Noble
is that the one on the bridge to the
to the dragon area
or is that the the one that's in this
area
because there's two
kitties
I think the miss one would be here right
this mic is way higher than usual
this guy's giving us advice on a boss
that I think we hit four times and it
does I'm not even kidding
oh the Monk on the bridge
that's in a different area
I don't think that's here damn
that rooster said [ __ ] you [ __ ]
okay I'm over it you guys can live
oh yeah
he's with all the dead soldiers
they everything does so much damage to
you in this game
spooky
spooky
I think if I take this they attack me
oh these guys will though
ghosts
damn
these are like the exact dogs from Elden
ring
I didn't know you could backstab a ghost
that's pretty cool
can I jump to the roof from here how do
I get up here
yeah
pork
I think I went too far
after I go around
yeah I have to go this way
[Music]
monkey
with a gun
if we need prayer beads we'll come back
do do
which we always need prayer beads but
we're gonna be fine
okay now we're on the roof
okay you guys ready for the hardest boss
in gaming
wait this is the Miss Noble
we got it
first try wow
Pro Gamer
why that's a boss I will never
understand
we just went in there dude
we went for it and we got it
artists boss down
dude this area is like low-key scary
I don't remember it being scary
rest also I think I can get the skill I
want
yeah this one death blows provide
Shinobi with an opportunity to breathe
recovers Vitality after performing a
death blow
you get a little Health back
massive
missed basic attacks can one tap your
health bar
I don't know how
it would ever get an attack off
you know
sorry
an evil Village
I always just run through here
bum
oh yeah there's things that come out of
the ground
where'd he go [ __ ]
go go go
all right where's the sake at
I always just run through here dude
would you ever stream the Neo series
I don't know
I
think
I would ever be too interested in
playing Neo I'm not gonna lie for like
from the gameplay I've seen I don't
think I would like it
but you never know never say never right
stop
give me your money
Divine confetti which we're gonna need
that's good against the Headless dudes
where's the gourd seat at
I don't think I've ever gotten one here
or I don't remember where it is
look
right
yeah I don't know what it is about Neo I
just don't want to play it
I have no reason to think that I just
don't
you know
I think that's pretty typical
can I Parry the Bell
these guys
sure can
foreign
by the tree where they come up from the
ground
gotcha
so over here
is this a tree
no
[ __ ] leave me alone
okay we found it we found it we're good
this area is terrifying I'm leaving
we're gone
oh
neo2 is really good skip the first one
just the fact that you can skip the
first one I don't know
maybe someday that's all I'll say about
that
have I played Dark Souls 2.
I play Dark Souls 2 for 6 hours
like
a month ago
and I just I just don't like it
it's not for me
that's all
people can like it I just don't
that's all I I just don't enjoy playing
the game at all
so I'm not gonna
is it Emma here oh I have to go to the
other place
what does this guy have actually
don't know
shinobikoi Shinobi Kai
okay
2000 for a gourd seed that's a lot
can I sell these are they the same price
I think they are
you know
guys I believe I tried Scholars Edition
I'm pretty sure I did yeah
I just don't enjoy the gameplay of Dark
Souls 2. that's it
people can like it if they want
I personally just do not and I don't
want to play it
yeah level adpd
yeah I just I find that funny that you
have to level your iframes
foreign
I wish I would come home and someone
would tell me that that'd be nice
I am so happy you're home
I don't know what that's like
wait I have the shrine key it was here
son of a [ __ ]
Dark Souls 2 and Dark Souls 3 are my
least favorite from software games
see I love Dark Souls 3.
Dark Souls 3 is my one of my faves
outside of bloodborne
hey you should try it Dee
maybe you'll like it
I don't think you know like there's a
lot of people that like it you know
they exist it's
I don't know why but
they can tell you why
okay where was I
can I uh
I'm forgetting where I was I'm not gonna
cap
we can go through the door now that we
have the key
sorry I'm looking at all the areas
bottomless hole no
it's here
people who try Dark Souls 3 and die to
gundir I died to gun deer a bunch of
times in my first playthrough like so
many times
so did everyone else I bet if they've
never played a Souls game before because
that was my first Souls game
my first Souls experience ever was
Dark Souls 3 and then it was gun deer
Harry
Chad ignore the giant snake trying to
kill us
ignore
I don't have the ability to dive I'm not
gonna cap I don't have it
[ __ ]
there we go
he's a joke to more experienced players
of course he is
gundier is insanely easy
but if you have no experience
everything's hard the first time you do
it right
then you do it more and more and more
and you get better and better and better
man
key
[Music]
I don't like killing the monkeys
this area is so cool though
[Music]
get back here
sir you're done
you're done hey hey okay you can stop
this is annoying I'm getting annoyed now
[Music]
midair huh
dude the music goes so hard in this game
when you're in battle
[Music]
so I believe we can fight the guardian
ape correct
[Music]
the next on deer is the coolest
I think gundier is a great boss
it's a tutorial boss you know
hmm
keep going down boys just keep going
down
does anyone know the way to killing the
snake
I think it's down here right
where I stab it in the head
[Music]
oh
mommy there we go
oh God
I reach that
God that swamp sound dude
wrong way
you need puppets here in Ninjutsu no
there's another way
I know that I know what you're thinking
of
but there's another way that's just to
distract the snake not kill it
which I believe is in here
conversation
[Music]
I have to fight a Shinobi monkey
is this not a boss
there we go
dude is gas coin a tutorial boss
no shot right
is he considered a tutorial
yeah I guess he's there before you go to
the church that would that kind of makes
sense
[Music]
you can use the kite to get the kill
[Music]
it's then poo Temple
all right I'll wait I'll wait I don't
think I'm in the right area I'm not
where I think I am
[Music]
yet
no
now I'm lost
I get lost in this game more than any
other Souls game I swear
I think I'm too low
you can't get up from here as he gets up
from there
I was wrong
go
yeah I would have thought that the
cleric beasts would be a
the tutorial boss but I could be wrong
about that
I think that's where we fight the monkey
yep
wait isn't this where a bunch of monkeys
are yep
just a whole group of them over there
just chilling
[Music]
okay
Guardian ape time
um
I don't know if I remember how to fight
this thing
I remember stage two being quite easy
actually
yo what up bro
okay
he mad
where you going dude
no like fire
[Music]
foreign
OST goes really hard
oh [ __ ] no come on that hitbox is insane
he's gonna poop he's gonna poop
he's gonna throw [ __ ]
thank you
I'm gonna heal off that one
not worth
it pooping inbound
no [ __ ] way
okay do I have a thing
or am I just dead
[Music]
do I have something antidote powder
this
okay we're good
foreign
was killing it from Health alone
there we go
[Music]
one of the coolest [ __ ] things I've
seen in gaming right there first time I
ever saw that I was like oh
split
and then
not not so dead guys
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
don't eat it
foreign
[Music]
I love the fact he puts his head back on
just to scream
whoops
oh I got no more thingies I was using my
fire
stop screaming
no no no no no no no no no no are you I
was doing it so perfectly
you got fast in this game
three
where are you going buddy
and there we go
kill it
so [ __ ] cool
that's one of the best boss fights in
all these games
it really is
it's a lot of fun
first try
yeah all those uh
like what to do came back to me pretty
quick
what's this
Shinobi eyes
increases the damage inflicted the
posture upon executing a Mercury counter
um
error
why not
okay
and then memory of the Guardian eight
you guys think they'll make a sakiro too
I don't know
I don't think they will I don't Maybe
Maybe
okay let's grab the flower
Lotus
okay now where do we go
can they even make DLC this late in the
game
because it came out
three years ago right
it might be too late for DLC because
they probably have like updated graphics
and [ __ ]
which I guess they could
[Music]
I agree with Muppets
perhaps the real Sakira too is the
friends we made along the way
reach
I like it
okay where do I go now
hmm
well let's go talk to Kuro now that we
have the flower
is a tutorial game what
what
no
I don't think so
huh
you're calling secure
jokes jokes jokes
foreign
foreign
we gotta get the Mortal blade
that's right
dude I love grapes holy [ __ ] grapes
Paige's diary
my ex-girlfriend's name is Paige ugh
I don't want to read it
oh we gotta ask her okay
guys purple shibiri grapes
Co
the world
I don't think you've ever known a page
IRL that was the first one I ever met
hopefully it's the last
kochiro
Immortal Severance scrap
with Mortal blade in hand my blood may
be shed
with my blood the aroma will be complete
the Divine realm will be in reach
Immortal Severance will be at hand I
must ask tomboy to assist with the
beheading
[Music]
don't you guys just have like names you
don't like for reasons
hi like I don't think I'll ever date a
page the name page ever again just
because of the name and that kind of
sucks
just leave an awful like oh
she couldn't do it I bet I could get
over it but man
oh come here
Perla I've never heard that name in my
life
foreign
I have never heard that name ever dude
that's crazy
that's crazy man
okay so I have to go
uh
uh how do I get to senpu Temple again
I don't remember
do I hold on I want to fix your chat
guys because you're way too small now
what the heck happened
let me fix that real quick
oops
labs
you guys are way too small you're much
you're much bigger than what I'm showing
you right now
you're much bigger you're better than
this okay
you're better than this chat
okay so you're let's go for a size 30.
fave
okay everybody type
[Music]
spam
just kidding don't is that big enough
up there top right
is that good
[Music]
y'all are definitely way too small
that's better I like that that's that
seems like a good decent size
okay ideal excellent
right I have to go to the main gate
don't I
oh I could eavesdrop on them
we're almost there
yes do what must be done
animes they're like oh
huh
they zoom in on their eyes while they go
oh
such anime
big anime
not temples nunny
I don't know why my throat hurts today
can I get down from here
honestly I could have just traveled that
would have been the better
no
you know no no shoot
oh
dude how would grapes make my throat
scratchy
that'll make no sense my guy
that was not worth it
um
we need to go this way I believe
can I get off
hello
whoops I thought I could jump on this
and I could not
as well as I thought
there we go
okay
Fair
[Music]
[ __ ] you I'm going I'm gone
so yeah
I have a mild grape allergy dude I I eat
grapes all the time
[Music]
are you saying that I've just been
slowly killing myself
eating grapes
[Music]
nope
this area and everything about it
they can develop anytime
so you're saying I could just develop a
grape allergy right now and die
sick
what a weird life we live huh
what's up here
I mean this item
[Music]
out is this guy's [ __ ] deaf
my purse black gun powder
pacifying agent
money
gobble gobble gobble
you're down bad pastor
it's so good
what am I locked onto in the water
foreign
yeah that's like a piranha or something
that's gonna kill me
okay here we go
most allergic reactions are mild I'm
allergic to peanuts
of any kind
kind of sucks
because I hear they're a great snack
which I have to eat it I can be around
peanut butter
[Music]
foreign
I have to eat it and if I do my throat
closes and I can't breathe
isn't that great
isn't that awesome
get a friend who died because a
restaurant ignored me and told he was
allergic
it's happened to me too dude I didn't
die but I had to like you know EpiPen
give me to Breathe Again
[Music]
[Music]
thanks blizzard
peanut dust I'm not sure about that
okay I have to ingest it
EMS
never died before not yet
this might be kind of dark but I think
I'm at a point in my life where
I don't know if any of you feel this way
might be kind of dark I don't know uh
I'm at a point in my life where if I
died I'd be like okay
it's whatever
you know
I wouldn't be like oh no damn right I'd
just be like ah
all right
damn that's you know I'd be like dude
that sucks but do I really care that
much
probably not you know what I'm saying
like that might be really really dark
I'm not sure but it's just like I guess
I died
foreign
[Music]
there is and just be like ah [ __ ] I died
and they'd be like yeah
all right what do we got next you know
like we're all gonna die anyway I don't
know why you know
why I'd care so much you know a lot of
people do
they don't want to die
oh yes
this is a good area
it's a bit dark yeah
but you know [ __ ] happens if I die it's
like you know whatever I've told my
parents this
you're like you know if something
happens where I get hit by a bus or
die in a car accident or accidentally
eating a peanut and die
I ain't gonna stress it that much and
then my dad goes no kidding you're not
gonna stress it you're dead
and I'm like yeah I know I'm dead but
just like when I realize that I'm dead
I'm not gonna be like no
let's be like ah
[Music]
darn
it's dark it's too dark sorry
but you know you know what I'm saying
also the game's talking about
immortality which is why I thought of it
where I'm thinking like would you guys
want to live forever
I don't think I would
I don't think I would at all
that sounds like a lot
I do not know your attacks
I can't see
monks are strong dude
yeah I know right
huh
exhausted just thinking about it
I mean I guess that's the conversation
is is immortality a blessing or a curse
it's hard to say
they didn't hear any of that
foreign
no I don't know about this guys there's
way too many of those
whoops
why are we talking about this oh am I
not supposed to have deep conversations
I'm sorry sorry
ignore me
at
there's Grandma
no I'm not all right
[Music]
foreign
can't open their own doors
a bunch of idiots
[Music]
much easier
[Music]
what's she talking about
[Music]
you that's what I'm saying
rice
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I think I have to go up there
nope I don't [ __ ] around with these guys
at all
nope see ya
it's about picking your battles
I don't think immortality would make
everyday meeting less hmm
I don't think it would either I just
wouldn't wanna
live forever that sounds really hard
hey man
whoa whoa whoa what am I doing
[Music]
nice
oh yeah
Robert I love this fight
can you attack normally sir
[Music]
I don't think yeah I can't hurt him at
all
what
is that far enough
no it's not
thank you
Greg I thought I could just strafe
there we go
[Laughter]
Roberto boom
such a well-designed fun boss
love it
Roberto
that'd be an awful way to die I don't
think you'd feel it I think he'd just
explode right
I don't know it's kind of dark too we're
getting dark today
Dumb Ways to Die
lots of dogs
I'm getting jumped
rip
damn
bye
um
die
gotcha
I can take you to the weird bucket boy
or Magikarp
room
[ __ ] all this no shot
I'm realizing there's a lot of areas in
this game that I just run through
quite a lot
you know why because they're hard
ow leave me alone
leave me alone
we're in boys
this is how you beat two of these guys
at the same time you open a door
oh and a monk
you just gotta open a door
it's pretty easy
I didn't do this I can
foreign
these guys are hard well they're not
hard but
they're hard to find
why is there one monkey missing
zombie
oh
by the way there's an invisible one
right behind me wait
[ __ ] you
foreign
they're chilling down there
I forget how to really handle this
in the fastest way
you gave him glasses his doctor
[Music]
whoa look at that
where is that even falling from it's
kind of cool
okay fire monkey
oh
I don't know about all that
there you are
can't this one like hear everything or
something
because I don't think you can catch it
by chasing it
if I remember right
where'd it go
that one's over there
[Music]
still following me
calling this a boss fight it's a gimmick
fight
it's a gimmick boss right
we like gimmicks
they're fun
there's the fire one
still running
See No Evil Hear no evil speak no evil
and do no evil
it's Ryan
it's right here
gotcha
then where's the last one
isn't it like hiding
not up here
on the tree
[Music]
not on the tree
Miss Noble hardest boss
fair enough
[Music]
foreign
the Bell to put them back in place
oh oh man
this
oh in my inventory
foreign
what's this Bell for I gotta sneeze
well I'm worried like why can't I see it
or find it where is it
the heck
[Music]
I already killed the one that was behind
me
[Music]
he's right [ __ ] there
we got him
okay he's running
[Music]
so what's the gimmick with this one will
it just keep running
or can I eventually catch it
no no no no no oh
[Music]
there we go
we got it
I took two minutes to be ishin
cool dude
yeah I think that one's just a normal
monkey I don't know
dog dog
[Music]
[Music]
dude wolf is so badass
he's so calm
I would like to be that calm
just
doing his thing
so many Subs we have Kevin
okay we got puppets here now
foreign
is the Miss Noble that we killed not the
real Miss Noble
is it like soldier of godric it can't be
killed
and it's a literal God
okay
none you
know
cause we can die twice
[ __ ]
I think he does die when he draws it
right
I think you just walk away kudo
come back later you have to get it
[Music]
[Music]
I wonder how many people come here and
just die in front of her
that'd be sad it's a sad existence
be hilarious if the credits just rolled
[Music]
I can't wait for the dragon fight
[Music]
I love that fight
whoa
that thing looks good
mortal blade
in odachi capable of slaying the undying
its Crimson blade will take the life of
any of those any Who Dares draw it
without the power of Resurrection one
cannot hope to wield this weapon with
what allows to defeat even infested
beings long concealed within tampu said
poo Temple the blade is inscribed with
its true name gracious gift of Tears
dope anatava
do you know me
so does she just sit here in front of
the Mortal blade at all times
it's malachette's blade
let's go dude
she likes candles
she has great hair
is
[Music]
I'm the only one who survived the
process
coconut Demas
Sogo
is
I feel like they underutilized this girl
she seems pretty cool
nondo
[Music]
rice
hi
okay yeah I want to do demon of hatred
is there something I have to do to
unlock that or do I just progress the
game and go to a certain area
okay mortal blade I got my rice
can I go back to that chick and give her
the rice
wait I can just go this way
[Music]
I got rice to fix my phone
excellent
Dragon return ending how many endings
are in this game
because I feel like we never see her
again
from the endings I've seen
[Music]
no
[Music]
foreign
I feel like they should have made
different
uh music for every combat scenario it's
always the same music
it's very aggressive no matter what I
feel like there was a bunch of different
types of
uh Combat music and Elden ring
okay
so now we have the Mortal blade let's go
back to Karo
mortal Severance purification Dragon
return and shura
which one should we do which one's the
best one see y'all
gotta keep the dialogue with the
Sculptor
and eventually he's gone and that's when
you know
gotcha
hello
it's in here reading can I sneak attack
him right now
yep eavesdrop hmm
[Music]
okay
you set all of them up we should
oh simple
example
videos
yeah sure are we in the game early right
I don't want to do that
I want to fight ishin
that's the most epic one solido
which I would argue is like maybe the
artist boss fight in all these games
maybe
hardest to learn
this kid wants to cut himself it's kind
of kind of cookies
yeah not fire issue
sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry
okay
can I cut this kid now oh come here
is it sword saying
the one where we fight ishin in the
flower field where he comes out of
genichiro
um
Disco
well that's where we have to beat that
yeah we have to I know where to go now
we have to fight the uh dancing lady
monk corrupted Monk
Gaga
I already threw myself in I already know
what's going on
[Music]
yeah we beat lady butterfly
yeah I already know what we're talking
about
let me go let me go there
where the heck's Emma
Emma
wait we do have court seeds
all right
might be here
no no no I know where to go
I know where to go
I got this
ashina
where is Emma
fit new do I have any tools yup
what does the finger whistle do Divine
abduction okay we've got all that
is any of this worth it guys
doing this [ __ ] I don't know I don't
think I've ever done that
we're good we're good okay
let's go
to
you
uh
we were in the Sunken Valley
and then
not there
not there
ashina depths
watermelon
this boss is uh is it optional this one
up here I think someone said that
we gotta talk to our boy he's still
going nuts
dude do you have a stick coming out of
your leg my guy
this guy literally has a tree coming out
of his leg
oh
Scotto you could
oh no oh no
I think our boys just a simp
there she is
this is terrifying
oh is she taller than you wolf
I think so wow
why are we crying
why do you cry
because I'm sad
good answer
[Music]
she know this
is
n't that a style in Japan guys where you
wear like a basket on your head that's a
thing right
you can still see through
Gucci
Lord sakuza
I don't know
wolf is only five eleven
how do you guys know this
oh we're in trouble
that's right
ghosty girl
foreign
[Music]
she annihilates my posture
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
sometimes I swear that [ __ ] just doesn't
work
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
come on I feel like I jumped a little
late on that one but that's okay
damn let's go first try
[Music]
I usually struggle with her
me
you don't know
Breath of Life shadow
did I already have that
maybe it's a different version
man imagine simping that hard couldn't
be oh is this him
is this him
damn bro
okay you do that really fast
wow
damn
okay
I'll be dead now
we gotta fix that real quick
I [ __ ] that up what's the best Souls
game what's the best Souls game do we
really want to talk about that oh God
hold on thank you for the five dollars
Luke I really appreciate that thank you
um
we really want to talk about that bro I
mean sheesh
okay so it should be
name
that
save
here we go but thank you Luke
thank you very much
hmm
what's the best Souls game
I think it that depends
on your preference of games that you
enjoy
so if you enjoy
like a fluent combat system
then sakiro might be the your best Souls
game
if you like atmosphere
good bosses good combat good lore
bloodborne which is my personal favorite
I think bloodborne is the best Souls
game to me
Dark Souls 3 is is fantastic it's got
everything you want in there it might
not be the best of all of it but
still really fun still really cool I
love it if you're into open worlds
with all that stuff in there as well
Elden ring is probably your best bet you
know what I'm saying hey what can I say
man best one in my opinion is these
three I just haven't played Elden or
sekira I recommend playing them and Dark
Souls 3 was my was my first Luke so
I feel you there
Dark Souls 3 is like a close second for
me like it for me it goes bloodborne
Dark Souls 3.
Elden ring sakiro Dark Souls 1 Dark
Souls 2. that's how that's how I feel
about it
and thank you for another five dollars
Luke I appreciate that man thank you
thank you thank you
get skills at idle stop telling me what
to do I'll do what I want people shut
the [ __ ] up thanks
thanks I'm gonna try bloodborne but that
one I want to try a look uh while I love
the aspect you should
try them all man you should play them
all they're all good games even Dark
Souls 2 is a good game that I don't like
that that's it
that's all man
but you'll enjoy it
you'll enjoy all of them I'm sure
I mean do I really even want all this
[ __ ]
why are you guys telling me to get
skills like who cares
yeah
play all of the games guys oh
she the only one
oh
she knows
yeah it's just not for me Luke that's
all I just don't enjoy it myself I
understand why others do that
yes some games are actually bad
like can we agree that Battlefield 2042
is what cheeks bad of a video game
it's just a bad game
crash
on
a nightmare
yeah bloodborne is PlayStation exclusive
E.T from Atari okay okay
yeah
it was you young the hotel
[Music]
yeah I have not enjoyed the last
well I mean I really liked uh
I really liked Modern Warfare 2019 Trey
yeah anthem's a bad game
[Music]
you know statue Buddha apogee found in
light pink cloth raised in prayer
between once Palms to restore a note of
resurrected power
I mean sway the juzo statue is to
express feeling a parental love
Lord sakuza please take this cloth and
use it to bundle this little one
so that he may live on in peace
thank you for the bless you will you
play God of War a hundred percent
absolutely
I think our boy's dead
but I'm gonna play the new bloodborne on
stream for sure
not the new bloodborne imagine
the uh
the new God of War
oh I broke it
way to stop glowing green too
sorry sorry there's no new bloodborne
guys I'm sorry that's my bad
no new bloodborne
today
sir you are strong as [ __ ]
got you there
do you think Elven ring will win game of
the year and new God of War depends on
the new God of War I don't know how good
it's gonna be
I don't know
ignoring that little meeting going on
over there and we're gonna go up here
boy here we go
corrupted monk time
[Music]
foreign
stomp on her head
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
getting anywhere
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
no I mean it's going up it's going up
[Music]
no that's timing sucks I shouldn't have
tried to do that
[Music]
come here come here
she's [ __ ] pointing at me dude it's
sick
[Music]
man
she just went right through it
[Music]
my posture
is trash
nice let's go
yeah didn't need it but
just go
I don't think I think Divine confetti
helps a bit there at least it'll get her
health down a little bit faster than we
were just now
for sure
what do you think about the Elden ring
mushroom Theory I don't want to start
any channel drama so you don't have to
answer just curious no there's no drama
uh I like that theory a lot you're
you're talking about the one by Zio
I like that one I think it he offers a
lot of evidence as to why that could be
the case
I don't think it's about mushrooms but
he's offering a lot of like solid
foundation as to why he thinks that and
that's cool
I like it
I mean I'm I'm the I make up a not
makeup but I come up with a bunch of
like
theories like that as well and I like it
that's one of my favorite parts of Eldon
ring is that there's a lot there that's
up for interpretation and I like it
yeah there's a lot of stuff on uh
the mushrooms
can I even do this yet
got their Stones such as this are
vicious omen
aliquin
nope
can't do it yet
yeah I played siamesha I liked it it was
pretty good
I've asked this 400 times
do you know about the huge skeleton of
the Church of propose
in this game what are you talking about
you The Fountainhead Aroma first where
do I get that
where do I have to give
yeah I was very short lucky but I did I
liked it
Elden ring mountaintops yeah the giant
skeletons yes yes
I gotta go to Kuro
did I get anything new
I think I did
okay
yes we killed Guardian ape
why am I not traveling
press the right button
oh I got the Mortal blade
that's what it was
oh that's right he's in trouble now
our boys in trouble
that's right
okay how do I get there
no
uh
I guess I can just go here
the Castle's under attack I believe
right
[Music]
foreign
bye buddy
what's this guy bitching about
don't worry brother I got you
I'm gonna have him help me out though
[Music]
my boy can still hurt me
oh son of a [ __ ]
nice
yup we have started the assault
[Applause]
wait do I randomly learn how to dive I
thought I had to unlock that uh ability
maybe not
I just unlocked it
[Applause]
interesting
can I not jump on these there we go
remind
wrong button yet again
what an odd place to learn after killing
a corrupted monk that you learn how to
swim the [ __ ] or how to dive
oh [ __ ] we gotta fight owl huh
I think that's next
oh God
nope
[ __ ] you
not fair
there we go
unless you guys want to do shura ending
which I doubt you do
[Music]
it's like doing the flame of chaos
ending pretty much
[Music]
[Music]
yeah we should do that Krusty for sure
foreign
[Music]
like so [ __ ] long it's crazy
quality muscle
oh boy
he's so tall
[Music]
guys there's no way you want to do Shira
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
we could do a new game plus
well that would take so much time
do it off stream
hmm
I don't know
I don't really like the shirt ending but
I like the Shira fights
let's do the shura ending in New Game
Plus that makes way more sense yeah okay
so we want to break the iron code
correct
yeah if we want to keep playing after we
beat the game we can do the shura ending
after in New Game Plus that makes way
more sense okay
so stay loyal to Kuro
yeah
compassion
I gotta poop
sick of you
nothing
he's capping right he's capping right
here boys
he's
a tricky little [ __ ]
[Music]
I don't care if he's constipated
oh
yeah
[Music]
such cool camera angles
that's so cool man
[Music]
you're wrong
welcome you
love it
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
okay
okay
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] you
[Music]
oh [ __ ] dick
[Music]
that's not good
considering I can't heal right now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
ERS around so long
got him cool
oh my victory
[ __ ] you
just light up on fire
[Music]
yeah stop telling me to thrust or I'm
gonna thrust into your mom
all right calm down
we're doing fine
oh God
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
at least I got the death blow to go keep
going Shadows die Thrice [ __ ]
[Music]
foreign
the [ __ ] out of me
oh
that before
is that why you were telling me to do
that
no
you guys were telling me to do that
you [ __ ]
I got makiri counter dude what the [ __ ]
no
no I had no idea that's what happened
that would happen and no [ __ ] clue
what the heck
that was a badass counter like can't cap
that was awesome
told you not to you didn't tell me why
you sons of [ __ ]
I should you know what like I'm so
surprised I did that
because I was doing great
I was doing amazing
and y'all are like let me ruin it
for Jake
let me ruin it for this guy
I trusted you chat
I trusted you I did
now I don't
and that goes for every single one of
you
even the people who were telling me not
to I don't trust you either now I don't
know who to believe
the trust is broken it's hard to get it
back
now the question is do you care probably
not
but
good one chat
good one
that's all I'll say
not bad
not bad
let's try that again because it was
going so good
[Music]
right thrusting
good enough
[Music]
all right we're already dead
this game is brutal man it really is
if you [ __ ] up you die
thank you
let me try and thrust
okay not a not a good attempt
not good
I was in it
and now I'm not and I'm blaming it on
you
I was in it doing great first try
probably would have been a first try and
then y'all
y'all [ __ ]
the flow's gone
honestly I'm just making excuses
you were pooping
was it a good poop
what do you plan on doing for 100k
gosh I don't know what do you guys want
oh
we're getting there slow and steady very
slow now I barely get any subs every day
but we don't lose
okay aggressive
[Music]
foreign
[ __ ]
such a tricky timing when he does that
oh that's not fair
wife ain't Fair
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Al you're being very aggressive this run
I'm gonna need you to calm down
[Music]
[Music]
actually fine when he does that
[Music]
scared me legit
glad I healed
[Music]
my game froze
[Music]
nice
[Music]
doesn't try to trick us again
foreign
[Music]
sure
can't go behind him because of the
poison
[Music]
oh that didn't hit
[Music]
dude I can't the door bruh
I'm down
[Music]
how does he not get poisoned it's still
poisoned
[Music]
look out
no shot
no way
[Music]
oh he just gets one hit in
and I'm dead
pairing everything perfectly I mess up
one time
dead
[Music]
no what is he doing I don't know what
that is okay that's fine
[Music]
too far away nope we're good
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
not fair
nope
it's gonna be tricky
that's why
nice
you almost had us there
[Music]
you bastard
thank you
[Music]
[ __ ] it
I wish I didn't [ __ ] it now
[Music]
[Music]
dude I I legit [ __ ] up twice that
entire fight
man
it's an endurance test
wow
the thing is when he hits you
oh
or when he staggers you
oh
yeah I can't believe you guys are giving
me like advice like we have him on the
ropes if I just don't [ __ ] up two
deflects we're good
[Music]
um
kill
ER I sure can would help there you're
not wrong but we clearly got it
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
that's three quarters my health gone
[Music]
come on
come on no stomp no stop
[Music]
[Music]
that was close I did a bloodborne
instead of a deflect
man bro
oh here they are
[Music]
I tried to [ __ ] pause and it didn't
pause
God damn it
they always call mid-fight
dude [ __ ] you bots
I'm blaming the Bots
[Music]
foreign
boys
got up crusty
[Music]
has YouTube addressed the bot thing
because it's kind of nuts
it's every stream
[Music]
come on let me heal
thank you
[Music]
let's get him there for a minute
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
doesn't care I feel like they do
what my character just
did you see my character he's facing the
opposite direction as I'm locked on for
an overeat what the heck just happened
what the F that was so weird my
character just decided to go this way
you just went
and I got hit
damn
oh this fight's [ __ ] hard
this fight is hard
right there
are we up
use the bundled thing to get res back
dude I bet this fight kills no hit runs
seems so hard
[Music]
I feel like I need to go at him a bit
more
like hit him you know
I feel like I'm only deflecting
sometimes
[Music]
this is good too
[ __ ] you
[Music]
back
[Music]
go
[Music]
good [ __ ]
where are you going you don't even know
foreign
you just did that move like three times
well that's not fair okay
it all matter we don't need to heal
yeah I was a bit more aggressive and we
got through that round a lot faster
all right
[ __ ] you
starch
[Music]
well I was not able to move which kind
of sucks
okay
no I forgot what button it was
I don't really use it that often
RT
[Music]
I was scared of the poison dude
[Music]
what just happened
[Music]
nice
good tips good tips good tips
[Music]
foreign
let's go
um
GG
Pro Gamer unlocked
how many tries that take like three or
four
it's not that bad
not bad at all
what's up Josh
good stuff boys good stuff good stuff
all right is our boy dead down here
rest rest
four tries it's not bad
I can't even tell you first time I
played this game how long I was on owl
like
I want to say it was an entire day was
like I had to like take frequent breaks
come in and out of it
it was a lot
oh
soak
Kroger
is Emma here
is
did I just walk by her
foreign foreign
you know you can have multiple
Prosthetics
no I had no idea
it's cool though
I walked right by her no shot
am I blind my blind old man oh hey Emma
yep
I was playing hard to get guys
I think it looks cool
what color you guys wanting I can change
it
do we know
we did do eavesdropping on girl
Brown
ah you see that's
on me
oh
[Music]
my mother
oh
are you gonna fight owl
City
foreign
red
oh
how about that
there's a red over there I forgot there
were two
there you go
green or yellow okay you paid for it
is that good
green
maybe I can get the yellow over there
like that
like green or yellow
is this good Luke
thank you for another two dollars I
appreciate it man
green looks good pretty cool
right
there's also another uh color right here
in the corner
like red
blue
you guys like this you good with this
I'm gonna do whatever Luke wants because
he paid for it
hair reveal
I kind of look like skiro right now I
got the ponytail in the back
[ __ ] yeah all right there you go Luke
gets it
Tony guys long hair is in for guys right
now looks good
hey can you see it
ponytail
okay
what should we do
I don't think I've ever done this before
sorry
why is it dark outside this you think
this is outside
this is a this is a basement over here
First Option okay
see no sinner this is another room
basement area
that leads to upstairs
oh
City
hi
yeah I I love my long hair
I'm trying to get it even longer like I
want to be able to like Let It Flow down
like right here
it goes to like right here right now
like just past my like face like my chin
rests on my shoulders just a bit but I
want it to be like here
like rust right here
but I've got
the flow the toe right now
okay let me
sneak eavesdrop
s so strong I wish I was
he talking about me
leave some women for the rest of us
I'm not gonna lie dude
I've only had compliments of my long
hair so far
not gonna lie
it's been pretty good
I don't really like having short hair
it's kind of feels lame you know
go to the grave at the back of the
castle at some point
which one
is
you going bald now
you need keeps or something
hi solution
this game really makes me want to learn
Japanese I said that yesterday but I
really do think that
is
now I know about second owl he's uh at
harada estate right
foreign
Google
but in English no
chat decided yesterday Japanese
do you think this was a girl this is a
guy bro
he's a dude
is there more I can say to him
go come here
once we make The Fountainhead incense we
can Infuse your clothes with their aroma
the incense burner what more do we need
Kira's a a dude I'm pretty sure he's a
dude
like it matters okay
weep weep
whoa Carlos no that is a not a word I
like
uh-uh
no
is that the look of things
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
okay
you got it brother
it's down here
whoa whoa whoa ishin you got some
[ __ ] downstairs dude
whoa
what the heck man
no thanks
okay guys where are we going now what
should we do
I don't know where to go
reminds you of Zelda
interesting
what should we do
where do you want to go oh I do it here
I thought he did it
well
foreign
good pick on the green Luke this looks
good I like it
oh
yeah we gotta cut him
hmm
korega
on
musioni natsukashi
um
foreign
I did not know that Archies that's
really cool probably because he trained
him so they have the same moose makes
sense and thank you for the the two
dollars man I appreciate it thank you
Google it
oh come here
so much talking in here you just bring
Dragon Tears to the Divine realm
that's of the cave so we're going to the
cave now right
where I was before
now that we have the incense or wait do
I have to pick it up hold on
I'll grab this no I think we got it okay
okay
did not need to rest but we'll take it
travel to right there
chain of deaths
wonder why it's called Wedding cave door
it's interesting is that reichardt's
voice yes all of my alerts are Elden
ring stuff
I think the next Eldon ring stream
streams that we're gonna do are the um
whatever the mod there is that makes the
game obnoxiously difficult I think would
be fun
I do want to play little nightmares this
month though
which we can get both those games done
in like two or three days
they're good October games like horror
games I think that'd be fun
try and try and mix up the content a
little bit which we've been doing but
only with Souls games
I remember seeing this first time and I
was like what the [ __ ]
I'm dead
thing just killed me
rolls credits
[Music]
this is so cool
we already did that d
[Music]
ude done and done
there's a playlist on the channel
if you missed it
and he just flops
nice
yeah I was looking for somber three that
was the entire randomized series we did
that less than a month ago
less than a month
do you think he killed me there and I
rose again like I
you know Shadows die twice
that'd be kind of cool if he did kill me
but I still
you still grabbed me
but then Shadows die twice
no damn that would be cool though
although it would kind of change the
vibe of this guy wouldn't it
I will say this time and time again
I want to know
the schedule of drugs
that the developers of this game
Hook when being this creative
I want to know what drugs
were taken
I really do
oh my God I forgot
this guy was the bane of my [ __ ]
existence
in 2019
what the [ __ ]
[Music]
okay
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
wait what
did we just get really lucky
[Applause]
[Music]
let's do that that fast
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
here's where it gets ridiculous
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
huh oh she broke my
posture
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I am
[Music]
this this [ __ ]
what an amazing try ow
[Music]
okay I need to not do that attack
at that point
okay no work
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I can see if she's
down here hold on Luke thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that [ __ ] comes out so fast
[Music]
[ __ ] you
are you kidding what is this Elven ring
throw out [ __ ] when they get low
health
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
just parrying perfectly 99 of the fight
I get staggered off of one bad deflect
and she does some
and then I die
oh
okay Joy's outside with my dad right now
I I baby
okay she's hanging out with my dad
outside
if I hear them come back in I'll go get
her I don't wanna my dad likes her
outside with her
with him
[Applause]
just breathe real quick and show us join
kkt
[Music]
I did the ichimanji again when I'm not
supposed to and now I'm just getting
upset okay
[Music]
we get a death blow we get another one
back
[Music]
Luke thank you again man
I will get her when I get her
[Music]
she's outside right now
that's her favorite spot to be why am I
doing that why what am I doing
[Music]
I swear to God this fight like kills my
brain
[Music]
cool
[Music]
there we go
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
that attack I don't think you can block
I swear to God
dude this boss is so
it she just goes nuts
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
holy [ __ ] that's a badass
oh
that fight is so hard
very frustrating fight
very frustrating fight
man okay we got it though we did it
excellent
does that not give me a prayer bead
actually
real for real
all right beautiful moment inbound
I always like coming here it's so pretty
just wanted you to know that I wanted to
see her
be who Joy I said she's outside
I don't see her anymore but if I hear
her come inside which I should be able
to
then I can go get her
I think she's busy right now
but thank you I I will if I see her
she usually comes down here
[Music]
you guys don't like this area
so pretty
I've missed quite a few beads that's
okay
it is what it is
a doobie would it be doing
foreign
these guys seem so happy
[Music]
that I don't want to kill him
hey
[Music]
well okay that's why we don't do that
foreign
[Music]
not just on this roof
[Music]
go go go
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
lightning attacks huh
[Music]
nice
I think tomalway was an eel person I
don't know
Maybe
known martial art form
I don't really care about those
let's get that [ __ ] it we'll finish it
out
[Music]
those guys are gonna suck my soul dude
no sucky suck
oh hi Grandma
oh sorry
what were you saying
okay
why is she here
oh what has she got on her plate
this is
I'll be right back
I think I'm safe here we'll we'll see I
guess
[Music]
nope
oh nope
she is helping my dad
catch a mole in the front yard that
they've been trying to get
for a while
so she's working right now
but probably not today
whoa
[Music]
go go go
foreign
[Music]
Joy's gotta work
he's a working dog
is she a good girl
you are my puppets
do these things actually help me
go kill
go murder
[Music]
ow
[Music]
righty then
[Music]
foreign
how do I know what this thing's doing
what a God
I'm going this way
all right
that was a big koi fish
[Music]
y
I don't think I've ever seen it jump out
of the water like that the [ __ ]
yes Krusty I will
um I think we'll do that after we beat
this game we'll play little nightmares
actually
they're playing soccer
big chillin
oh I am not in the area I thought I was
in
ow
[Music]
en nope I don't want to fight it I don't
want to fight this
no
please no
no
[Music]
okay cool
I don't know where I am right now
the [ __ ] was that oh
what was that
damn son
get some milk
nope nope
not again
how do I get out of here
I'm scared
is there somewhere I can go
okay so Lightning goes through water
that's right
there's no way they always leave ways to
get out of these areas
there's no way I just die
interview
I'll join myself
together
you don't trip on Joy I was trying to
say I just wanted to let you know I
wanted to see her keep killing it DOC I
prefer watching you just whenever keep
killing it dog thank you Luke I
appreciate it man thank you for all the
super chats I will get joy on stream
when I can
but she is working currently okay I
think I do have to die
that's kind of weird
well thank you Luke
yeah someone said go kill that guy and
I'm like I can't get out of the water my
dude
I can't get out of the water
another fish nope
okay
yeah I'm not gonna lie this area is
really pretty but I don't ever spend a
lot of time here
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's not go back in the water
[Music]
I don't think you can link things in
chat across you if that's what you're
trying to do
[Music]
I'm really confused at where I'm at
okay here we go
I barely beat this game won't lie you
get Guardian ape yet yes master we did
beat the guardian ape
if you got that far you got about
halfway through the game I'd say
so thank you for the five I appreciate
it
[Music]
but I recommend this game big time it's
great
it is very hard
what is hitting me
you are a mass ER Archer
the best Archer
in all the lands
but thank you again master I appreciate
it thank you thank you
foreign
I don't know what I'm hearing right now
and I I don't like it
[Music]
go go
[Music]
we're good
[Music]
you smeared poop on millennia
that's a little gross
all right
soccer lightning chick
okay that was a little early
um I did the early thing again
come on
I want to get it
I'm fine with this too honestly
you get a prayer bead from this chick
okay
interesting the boss fights in this game
are
they're odd aren't they guys are you
[ __ ] kidding me
that I can't jump back there
I am gonna poop my pants
Who's down bad everybody
good
why'd you smear [ __ ] all over Melania
it's pretty weird
I think she's just misunderstood
[Music]
you know what this one
which which statue the one that was near
the other the other one whatever
yeah this area is not my favorite I'm
not gonna cap
it's very pretty
but damn
kind of shits on me huh
okay can I go in the water now
bulging Court wow
[Music]
foreign
how the hell did you get out here
I managed to take a close look at the
Knights Cavalry horse and the horse's
menacing it actually it really is man
if you look closely at a lot of things
in Elden ring they're [ __ ]
oh I always forget about homework
why are you helping me
[Music]
foreign
isn't it crazy that this game won game
of the year and bloodborne didn't
because like
like what I'm three quarters of the way
through the game for the most part
this game has great combat but I am like
the more I'm thinking about it
I run through a lot of areas just to get
to bosses
I really like the music but it like the
combat music only has one type of music
which I didn't think would bother me but
it kind of is that no matter what combat
I'm in it's always the same music
this is beautiful though the areas are
very pretty
but I'm just running through them a lot
which
I would see it as being very annoying to
have to run through all of the enemies
in all of these areas not run through
but defeat all of the enemies to get to
the statues
oh
[Music]
and some of the boss fights like that
was a boss fight that that lightning
ball chick
on the
on the tree
some of the boss fights are very not
memorable in any way shape or form
what
a lot of the bosses are very memorable
so they're they're mixed in there
it's interesting I would definitely give
bloodborne game of the year over this
game
but that's just preference also the
combat is obviously incredible
probably the best yeah I would say it's
the best combat let's say bloodborne's
pretty close though
combat wise
very good
oh here we go boys
[ __ ]
big fish
Jesus
big fish
oh [ __ ] go go go
spooky no go down
thank you
up okay
more Water Combat
yeah there really isn't is there well
there's one isn't there a headless
underwater somewhere I think
but I wish there was more yeah
bloodborne's less accessible
let's see that
gross
ah excellent
perfect now we don't have to do that
again
I'm gonna leave all these guys alone
just let them enjoy their meal of
whatever it is
[Music]
now we're going into one of my favorite
boss fights
[Music]
the camera
[Music]
all right I'll fight you I'll fight you
[Music]
thank you
not dodgeable got it
what I didn't grab it I guess the [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
yep
yep
oh
nice gourd seed
foreign
[Music]
I'm not reading your your messages for a
reason
okay
now we can just go
kind of reminds me of the Ring City
DLC
in Dark Souls 3 where we break the egg
right before Gail
kind of sad
this fight's so
so pretty
thank you
[Music]
I don't think it's meant to be extremely
hard
it's meant to be a spectacle which it is
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
whoa
what
[Music]
nah
[Music]
don't let me jump off man come on
they're too close
there we go
yeah fried frog I would say either play
Dark Souls 3 or because if you've only
played eldering before dark souls 3 is
the closest
in terms of like being the same type of
mechanics and stuff
other than that play bloodborne sakiro
Dark Souls 1 is getting pretty old at
this point
it it's tough to go back to Dark Souls 1
sometimes it's quite old
[Music]
so cool yeah it's a great game but it is
getting old
Dark Souls one
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what that didn't seem fair
I'm not deflecting it shut up
[Music]
[Music]
oh come on
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
again right here
yep
[Music]
dude and I dodged The Comeback what the
heck
[Music]
oh no
[Music]
whoops
[ __ ] that one up boys
[Music]
I don't even know what just happened but
I loved it
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
it does kind of remind you of eldenbeast
that's a good point taco
who's harder Gale or orphan orphan
orphans
very very very hard
Gail's hard too but orphan's harder
I think in general
we got his tear we made him cry
the vine dragon
the vine dragon's tears
is she
someone
so cool
I don't know no we're just kind of
playing the game
we'll see what we got at the end
I think we'll have to finish tomorrow
secret passage key
oh no
oh actually this is the end of the game
isn't it
oh I locked myself out
well
we were thinking of doing a new game
plus anyway
is the secret boss isn't the um
what I'm the of the area over here is it
the big um fire guy I'm forgetting the
name of it
I got three
we got all these
as we'll get this
[ __ ] it
demon of hatred
I can still do the demon
that doesn't sound
it sounds lamb
very long
what is that
what
upgrade the gourd yeah let me just
I think she's mourning can I still give
her my seed
s
oh I can't okay cool
yeah I had two that's good
okay
give her your seed that's what I do
right that's what needs to be done
I give her my seed
idiot
I have to reactivate all of the idols
I also didn't rest
whoops
oh there's a battle going on out here
oh I'm sorry
[Music]
are you crying
[Music]
and still go over here
honestly I don't know why I wanted to
but here I am
what kite are you guys talking about
[Music]
is there an actual kite
why will it not grab sometimes thank you
go
that right there
[Music]
how do I use that
it's way up there
I can grapple it
foreign
okay
[Music]
fair enough fair enough
[Music]
it didn't seem worth it at all
[Music]
the
grave
is this the grave you're talking about
[Music]
sad
[Music]
that's for purification ending
[Music]
Gaston sugar
Emma would be there she's not there
okay
foreign
seems like a bad time for this
like a really bad time
[Music]
foreign
this is dope
[Music]
foreign
I see an issue
[ __ ]
telling you dude when there's more than
one person involved in a fight it's like
impossible
[Music]
just let me up please
please
[Music]
trying to remember where I am okay
foreign
leave me alone
in hell
[Music]
okay
we're going to the secret passage right
like that's our goal
I have no idea up here com
honestly bloodborne holds up graphically
it's not a frame rate is the only issue
wow
you good bro
[Music]
interesting position for this oh okay
is this demon of hatred yep sure is
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] I'm pretty sure I've only done
this once and it was years ago
three
[Music]
cool
okay how do you beat this
can I Parry this guy
I don't remember
okay
ow
[Music]
ride them like a bloodborne boss
[Music]
dude I'm literally not even getting
burned by him okay
it's in a bonfire
[Music]
[Music]
huh
dude
so don't Perry that
okay
foreign
[Applause]
wow
what is that
it goes Bing and he goes
it's like a charge attack
he just headbutted me
I don't know what that is but I don't
like it that's some [ __ ] it's so
fast
okay
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
so
this fight seems like some [ __ ] bro
I'm not gonna lie
[Music]
I can't I can't I can't even see it holy
[ __ ]
thank you
he's just doing it
okay the jump works
[Music]
this is stage one of three
what
[ __ ] dude oh my God this seems awful
this seems actually awful
[Music]
foreign
this fight
is completely different from the rest of
the game
whoa
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this doesn't feel like anything of like
Guardian monkey
I am not enjoying this at all
foreign
and I guess my camera is just keeping me
in place okay
okay this is so far this is [ __ ]
awful
I'm like I don't even remembered doing
this at all
wow
huh
tomorrow
[Applause]
well why are they changing the mechanics
of the game
I don't get that
this is entirely different from the rest
of the game
foreign
what do you want me to deflect fire
what's there to deflect
I'm not using all that [ __ ] com
I should based on the mechanics of the
rest of the game beat this guy with my
sword and deflecting
for sure
if I have to use all that [ __ ] I am
gonna quit this boss I'm not even
kidding
press and deflect I guess it
I got no indication of that at all there
he just did it
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
so far
[Applause]
foreign
do you not see what you're saying maggot
I I have a [ __ ] sword
foreign
the [ __ ] are you talking about
[Music]
[Music]
dude I don't like this at all bro
I'm sorry I do not like this is the
first time I feel like they've just
completely changed the mechanics of the
entire [ __ ] game
this is weird
I actually don't like this at all
like it's fine to have different bosses
I guess but like what the [ __ ] I feel
like I
I don't know
[Music]
like everything I've learned through the
game
is like throw it out the window for this
guy
which I do not like
and it comes out of nowhere like what
foreign
[Music]
yeah that's that's all I'm saying none
of what I've learned in the game applies
to this boss
that's [ __ ]
I don't like that at all man
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
maggot you seem like a well you seem
like a complete idiot to me watch some
videos
if I have to leave the game to go watch
how to do a boss
do you not
holy [ __ ]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh my God
[Music]
oh my God
hitting the flex man
maggot are you trolling or are you being
like dead ass right now
you're just being a straight up dick
Shut the [ __ ] up
you do not have the social awareness to
shut the [ __ ] up every once in a while
I don't know why I'm asking that it's
pretty clear you don't
I hate the attack oh [ __ ]
comes out of nowhere
I want you to win telling me to leave
the game and like just spamming [ __ ] of
like
back seating like shut the [ __ ] up
my God how do you not figure that out or
read the room in any way shape or form
goodness
I'm hitting the flag there's nothing
okay
to be fair a lot of people don't want to
read the room yeah they they can figure
out how to shut the [ __ ] up when they
don't like understand whatever dude
[Music]
dude I'm I'm locked in an animation
what does the game want me to do
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I like this boss
I don't like it
this is my least favorite boss in the
game not just because it's killing me
but just like all I'm thinking about is
nothing of what I did the entire game
has anything to do with this fight at
all
it's weird
and then obviously we got maggot baby in
the [ __ ] chat this is pissing me off
on purpose has to be
I mean he hits me once and I'm pretty
much dead like my whole health bars is
all the way down when he like I'm
deflecting his fire hits me I'm pretty
much dead
I don't know this is weird
foreign
oh no
yeah I'm learning it I'm trying to and
then I have people in the chat just like
telling me what to do over and over
again it's frustrating man read the room
I will figure it out
got up
[Applause]
I'm gonna do it my way though
foreign
[Music]
dude I have died to this guy
more times that I've died in the entire
game
in 15 minutes of me trying this guy
that's insane
the [ __ ]
from
Lim grave to the mountaintops to the
Giants at like level 30.
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I thought he was gonna throw fire or
something
dude I like never mind
D I don't think you're
I don't get it
wow
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
deflect
how are you not getting the like I don't
want to watch your video I don't want
help let me figure it out
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
better it's just amazing how quickly I'm
dying
can we speak English please in chat if
you're gonna
Park why are we I don't know what
language that is
[Music]
foreign
oh [ __ ]
foreign
[Music]
if you can't speak English then
goodbye maggot
you have one literally one more chance
stop telling me what to do or I'm gonna
ban you just stop I've I've asked so
many times stop telling me what to do
stop giving me a guide let me figure it
out
please I don't want your tip like how
are you not understanding that that's
what I'm saying the social
unawareness to not understand that I
don't want your [ __ ] help
I've said it so many times 20 minutes
please
it's insane
please
how are you not getting it
[Music]
how many times can I say it
God
foreign
there's the fourth attack
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
do I run away when he does that probably
he does it every time if I run Adam fast
enough then I can get underneath it
it's just amazing how fast everything
kills me from this guy it's
every attack
like go go go go go go okay
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
the red marker that comes up when he
does that
I can't see it because it like Blends
into the fire in his color it's weird
why are we speaking a whole bunch of
different languages now what happened to
Chad
what was that all the way down
I mean I know I can do it it's just
gonna take me a while
[Music]
should throw [ __ ] at me
how do I avoid that that seems kind of
insane it pretty much just kills me
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
so
it works sometimes though
no
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
the easiest difficulty in sakuro of
course of course
I'm out of water bro
damn
[Applause]
dude
I'm I try to
it's like instinct to just dodge but I
gotta jump
foreign
[Music]
deflect man
doesn't seem to matter
foreign
guy who beat boss in 120 seconds I'm
sure you did I'm sure there are people
who know how to fight this boss play the
game every day
I think I bought this guy one time four
years ago three years ago whatever
whenever the game came out
foreign
the tree wouldn't let me grapple
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
done
what is stage two like
probably something that's going to
explode and kill me
[Music]
huh
[Music]
oh that's a lot that's a lot
[Music]
[Music]
oh
go go go wait wait wait no
okay
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
some differences
[Music]
see
[Music]
[Music]
what do I do there man can I jump it
maybe
it's the only thing I can think of
[Music]
it's a jump okay
[Music]
as I just run into it
was that the same attack
I think it was
so like no fight in the game has been
all about wearing down a health bar
and this guy like is all about the
health bar
[Music]
which is strange
[Music]
okay so he's not gonna do the thing here
see I started running right away but
still got hit
what's up with that all right
well the bowl yeah the Bowl's a joke
compared to this
I haven't seen a headbutt in 10 minutes
so I there's no way I can track it down
there
see I don't know what to do
when he runs further away sometimes
[Music]
I don't want to do another attempt
I'll heal
[Music]
that seems more consistent
depends on how far he runs away
no way I was right underneath them dude
he's not a required boss therefore he
can afford to be different from the
regular bosses
okay
[Applause]
there's your reasoning I guess
saw that coming
the orphan of costs had every mechanic
in the entire game within the fight he
was just extremely difficult this is
just totally different from the rest of
the game
foreign
no I'm right next to a wall
okay that'll work
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
as soon as I started running toward him
I knew I was going to get blasted
foreign
draw that good against this guy
I can't use ichimanji so whatever
that doesn't matter
this is a whistle
I have a question is this uh is this guy
our
the guy who carves the Buddha
is that the lore
is this what he turned into somehow
or is it some
something else
it is
what happened
you know what's I
dude I looked at his knees and I'm like
it looks like the I don't know
interesting
so instead of us becoming Shira he
became sure
never let go of his hatred
damn all right that's kind of cool
sick
so we're fighting that guy who helped us
through the whole game
yeah I know there's a shura ending
is that what we turn into
damn
uh
I don't know I'm gonna keep doing it
this way
[Music]
[Applause]
I don't want to ruin the flow
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
there's times to use it though clearly
where he's staggered I think is the best
but it does a lot
[Applause]
[Music]
well that's just pure pain
gotta sheath it back into
[Music]
you can literally jump in any direction
on this
[Music]
fair enough
[Music]
fair enough
[Music]
[Music]
like never does that attack
not the top [ __ ]
I glitch him out no
wait I couldn't see it at all
I couldn't see it at all
the little logo I also didn't hear it
but you know that could be because he's
screaming and then he's the same color
as though
the emblem
this is probably not good
foreign
I think I'm too far away
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
initially that reached me
nice
[ __ ] it
that was a mistake
now blaming what color is it I feel like
that's an a thing I can blame I can't
see the logo
it Blends in I'm just saying why I
didn't dodge it
oh my God this guy's [ __ ] insane
foreign
[Music]
foreign
I feel like I'm hitting deflect
and then I die anyway
must mean I don't have the flag I'm not
hitting the flag
see my head button 15 minutes
pretty much always does that every time
every time
[Music]
is he covering his eyes every time he
does that
kind of cool
[Music]
[Music]
my fault
I don't like this
okay
[Music]
can't hurt him there so whatever
[Music]
I can jump and grapple him I see okay
[Music]
[Music]
is he doing nothing no okay
foreign
[Music]
attack
that's one of the attacks I don't
understand how sometimes I get under and
sometimes I don't
thank you
[Music]
that's a weird one
[Music]
[Music]
no I [ __ ] can't see because I'm old
old
I do like the music
[Music]
okay so no shot I'm getting to him
before he does some firebomb attack
that right there
[Music]
[Music]
that attack right there I don't I don't
get it
sometimes I get under him sometimes I
don't
felt like I was running right away maybe
not
[Music]
where is this combo from
wherever you want okay
just pulled he pulled out some [ __ ]
[ __ ] I haven't seen
in I don't know how long I've been doing
this
[Applause]
foreign
I hit the wrong button
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I deflected the first one but not the
second one
okay Nova
I'll change the title just for you
foreign
I should have known I literally knew as
soon as I started running that there's
no way
sometimes he jumps so far away
[Music]
[Music]
look at that
zenarnia
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
dude ice there's no way like I might
have doubled my amount of debts to this
boss
foreign
I've doubled the amount of times I've
died in this guy more than I have in the
rest of the game
easily
I might have I died like 5
main game
and then this this insane
that was not a good time
it was
foreign
nope nope nope nope [ __ ] you
you're baiting
[Music]
[Music]
why didn't I heal what
my character just didn't heal
[Music]
nope I don't like it
does it every time
sometimes he doesn't do two though
excellent
[Music]
it's that attack okay
[Music]
go
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
that
[Music]
in animation
you're in the like you deflect and
you're in an animation where you hold it
down and the camera changes and he's
still doing the other fire attack and I
can't move what the [ __ ] that's such BS
damn it dude
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
there's just so much [ __ ] that this
[ __ ] boss dude
wrong button yet again
I'm out of water
[Applause]
[Music]
how come sometimes he does one headbutt
and sometimes he does three
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I'm not gonna lie that dude laying on
the ground I thought that was me
there's lots of dudes on the ground
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
nope
more okay
is there not enough fire in this fight
dude we need more fire
[Music]
standing
in a bonfire
you should take a break
you're right you should stop commenting
no it worked that time okay
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
gets me
pretty much every time
I don't know what it is about it
trying to get under him
it's pretty much sweeping right in
between his legs
I don't get it he's going like that
and sometimes I'm in there and he'll do
the same thing and I'm fine some attacks
hit
at certain times and other times they
don't
[Music]
I don't get it
that one
it's literally that attack and the rest
of the attacks are fine I don't know
what it is
it's like he does something else
in my head
foreign it's making me back off like I
don't know how to not
I want to go underneath them but then
that one attack that gets me every time
is like making me not want to
[Music]
no I'm
dodging makes no sense
[Music]
he's using two different attacks they
look exactly the same as what I'm saying
I know they're different they just look
exactly the same and I can't tell the
difference
it is a different attack
this same looks the same to me
[Music]
[Music]
I don't I don't like this
[Music]
[Music]
should be okay
[Music]
I'm literally behind him
[Music]
and it still hits me
that was there was the attack
that was the one
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
I'm I'm jumping in the air man am I just
doing it too late
it's dope
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
think he'd do that dude I just didn't
think he'd do it and he did it
you did the whole thing you did the
thing the one thing that I couldn't do
and he did it
Chad if I can dodge that one attack I
will
I'll I'll come somewhere I I don't know
I can't even think right now
so I just parried it but it still hurt
me
so I don't want to do that
there it is that's the attack
so if I just see it coming
that sucks
uh this is gonna be close
foreign
[Music]
that was my fault that's fine
nope all bad bad bad bad bad bad bad
entirely my fault
okay I thought running to the side would
be enough it was not
[Music]
foreign
dude I hate that [ __ ]
that it it's literally all down to that
one that attack right there is what's
killing me
I think I just have to see it coming
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I got hit by everything else but going
right seems to work
okay
good call
now we know
that'll work
[Music]
what what I heard the deflect and I'm
still hit
Oh I thought that was it [ __ ]
we got headbutts
uh
bruh
[Music]
why is jumping not working anymore
it's literally just stopped working the
last few times I've done that
[Music]
so straight on goes up okay
[Music]
do you hear that sound
what just happened
the heck that was weird
I heard like slamming of a desk
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
kill me here damn
okay just avoided it entirely excellent
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
bloodborne dude
collect the feet
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
I feel like that attack is only in stage
two actually
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
foreign
God
come on I'm I just let me run backwards
dude
just kill me please
kill me
let me go again
[Music]
foreign
to the side man like [ __ ] sometimes it
hits sometimes it doesn't that makes me
so mad
no consistency
that's consistent
still struggling with that one dude I
can't I can't see it coming I just don't
see it it's so quick
I just need to dodge to the right when I
see it
there's so many things to like think
about in this fight that just very very
difficult
there we go
foreign
button and then stop myself
[Music]
just deflect you dumbass
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
why am I doing that
I'll never know
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
too far
I'm just incapable of deflections now
this boss hates it
that was weird
oh
this is too early
this didn't do it right I know what I
know what to do in phase two phase one
with everything it's just doing it
is the hard part
okay I went a little hard in the paint
there like that's my fault completely
dude I literally can't deflect though
yeah just go again
let's go again
dude the the last thing you guys need to
tell me is to take a breather
don't tell me to do that
I will bang my head into a wall until I
beat this that's how I am right now
that's how it's gonna be don't even try
thank you
I have my pattern for dodging that now
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
that time this didn't work I think I
don't know
[Music]
[Music]
yet again it's I know what to do it's
just physically pressing the buttons
correctly to be able to do it
is where I'm at currently
which I couldn't say that an hour ago
that's progress
oh
I guess
[Music]
that was fast sir
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I hate how I can't hit him here I really
want to
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
bonfire
future
[Music]
I've died to that particular bonfire
before that exact one how is that
possible so I got scared of it
damn it
foreign
you went really far that time
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
I don't think I got hit I didn't get hit
holy [ __ ]
Flawless stage one
[Music]
it's over now
back to reality real quick
[Music]
you can't Dodge those Jake you just
can't man
[Music]
he just didn't do anything I wanted him
to do in the second stage nothing he did
every attack that I don't like all in a
row [ __ ]
hitless phase one wouldn't have been
worse stage two
couldn't have been worse
[Music]
[Music]
where it is that coming from where's
where is all of this
I feel like I've seen any of that at any
point
[Music]
whatever whatever whatever whatever
[Music]
foreign
so much to think about
wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what the [ __ ]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
no
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
sure
[Music]
oh my God
I'm I'm I do that I'm underneath you you
[ __ ]
I must have been a millimeter
a millimeter off bro
[Music]
foreign
[ __ ] your headbutt [ __ ]
[Music]
Ma
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
why
why he just did the
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
was there
the tower got in the way oh hi metal hi
Stan I haven't been reading Chad I'm not
gonna lie
I mean I can't look at chat during this
I just can't
I did the first 20 minutes of the fight
and I thought I was gonna kill somebody
in a video game
[ __ ] bonfire over here man
this is my bad it's completely the wrong
direction
go again
which masochist suggested this in the
first place you're the guy
that I was mad at
my timing's off with that attack now
that attack is the death of me bro it
really is
go again
go again
bad timing sex bots
LOL
yeah I'll leave it to you soon
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
I'm gonna get this guys it's gonna
happen
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
oh God
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
he's glitching out man what the [ __ ]
dude
okay
[Music]
I don't know what just happened
no clue
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
timing man it [ __ ] dude
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
just
that attack
Dodge
what did I get hit by
all right
we're saying Divine confetti and AKO
sugar
I'll use it for stage two
I'll I'll throw it on
this
boost attack power
[Music]
[Applause]
what the [ __ ]
just heal and get over it [ __ ]
what are you guys talking about
[Applause]
[Music]
and what is it a [ __ ] this [ __ ] man
this that [ __ ] attack
he goes
yeah
oh it's just such awkward timing
[Music]
foreign
why is it even possible for the boss to
even hit me when I'm my character is in
an animation that I can't get out of
that makes no sense
I can't move he's doing the thing like
where the camera playing whatever
foreign
I thought he would stagger that's the
only reason I did it I was like 99 sure
he would stagger and then he didn't
foreign
99 sure he would stagger
and I was wrong
I was incorrect on that statement
we had such a good flow going with stage
one and now it's just not going well
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
does he always do that at the beginning
or something
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I got
cucked by the tower
foreign
ass
you cheese butthole boss
you know exactly what's gonna kill me
and you just throw all that [ __ ] out
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I'm starting to get mad
I like just didn't even think just now I
just like took it I don't know why
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I can't even I thought I healed way
earlier and I didn't
that was just dumb
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
stop running away bro
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I thought I was in stage two
some reason
nice
[Music]
I knew it I knew it that was my belt
that was my bad
go again kill me
[Music]
oh I've definitely like trickled maybe
even quadrupled the amount of debts to
this boss
combined with the rest of the game
for sure
it's not even close
thank you
yeah I'm off I'm off I'm off now
it was bad
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I did not see or hear that in the the
thingy
I did not see or hear it did anybody
else
there it is
[Music]
I haven't seen that button 15 minutes
dude
can't Dodge a headbutt
yep I'll throw the ax next time buddy
I will throw the ax as hard as I can
[Music]
foreign
okay hi hello
[Music]
[Music]
Kitty's in my [ __ ]
thank you
pride thing at this point
[Music]
do the thing
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I don't have any more grapes
[Music]
the grapes are gone
they were gone four hours ago
foreign
foreign
[Music]
keep hitting that dick
[Music]
[ __ ]
that hit me huh
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
no indication there at all again
[Music]
[Music]
there you go that's what's supposed to
happen
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I got out of that by panicking
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
deflect this is the deflect button this
is it this button right here is the
deflect button and I don't get a deflect
probably because you didn't time it
right you dumb [ __ ]
you were too late or too early who knows
but it hit you it hit you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
doesn't matter doesn't matter
um
[Music]
lands in a bonfire
okay interesting
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
bro
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
what
[Music]
[Music]
I think it's a jump under jump or
something
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
that was new
you can do that now I'm thinking of like
15 different things in this fight man
constantly
[Applause]
at least we saw it
game froze
foreign
[Music]
huh
[Music]
I thought he was doing something else
man damn it
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I'm just not seeing that attack now for
some reason
he's doing all kinds of [ __ ] I literally
haven't seen before
[Music]
I'm Not Dead
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
pretty much every time he does exactly
that
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
wow
you've got this chain send his flaming
orange butt back to the underworld
thank you ghastly I appreciate you very
much I am very close to beating this
boss
honestly I just lost to a tree
I didn't even lose to the boss I lost to
a tree
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign why did he do that so fast
why why did he do that so quick that
time
what triggered him to do it quicker than
usual
did he just hit a wall
so weird
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
ers
this wasn't it wasn't the one
just was not the one
Pro Gamer absolutely destroys sakiro
shut your [ __ ] dumb ass up you [ __ ]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
did not see the thing
[Music]
go again
[Music]
I didn't see the indicator or here
[Music]
nada
nothing
just doing it
oh I'm about to lose my mind on this
boss dude
I've already lost my mind I don't know
why I say I'm about to
five six minutes
I'm really rocking the head right now
that's being mean to me I'm telling on
you chat
I'm telling Cole that you guys have been
mean
[Applause]
I want you to know I beat monk in one
try earlier today one try Cole
it was like two tries actually
hit that ball sack baby
whoever's saying why aren't you
attacking out of the air it won't let me
not a thing
at least with this grapple
yeah that's when the game came out cool
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
on that one
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I was right you did some [ __ ] dude
stop yelling
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm gonna drink your blood
in 10 minutes
no indicator again I don't know what's
up with that
[Music]
foreign
I'm secretly a vampire and anyone that
tells me what to do or backseat games
I'm gonna turn you into a vampire as
well
I'm gonna do it
[Music]
happy Halloween jerk
foreign
I am going to reward myself
with Chipotle
when I beat this guy
I deserve it
that's what I'm saying Priscilla
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that was my yell
there you go
I'm gonna get chips and queso as well
that's the real treat
am I Adam McFlurry on it
I don't really like McFlurries never
mind
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
please do it more
[Music]
I've lost my mind
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
heal it off get over it
[Music]
[Music]
no way I [ __ ] jumped I
[Music]
what
he he doubled up
foreign
I want to say I want to point out that
this is the best music in the game
[Applause]
foreign
mm-hmm
this is America
don't catch you slipping though
[Music]
just got caught by a hill
[Music]
[ __ ] you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
I went for it boys
[Music]
foreign
it was a mistake
[Music]
look at how [ __ ] early agent
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
no kids
foreign
no healing stage three
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
don't have Divine grass
[Music]
[Music]
oh the the castle wall the [ __ ] wall
dude ah
the the [ __ ] wall man
God
foreign
this [ __ ] Boss Arena stop completely
getting in my way there's [ __ ]
everywhere
all right
all I have to do is Dodge forward and
he'll break right through it but instead
he'll just run
right into the fence
[Music]
I disagree
foreign
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
not even worth
kill me
[Music]
it's gonna happen guys we're really
close
it's gonna happen we're gonna get that
perfect run
it'll happen
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
like
I'm hitting deflect I'm hitting the
[ __ ] button man
it doesn't matter
it just hits me sometimes
[Music]
what are you doing
some [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
where where is that coming from
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
no I'm
[Music]
I I died to Stomps
it's the only [ __ ] I got hit by Stomps
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
flawless
[Music]
thank you
no
[Music]
I don't know why that hit me
[Music]
three
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that insta just eatsters
God damn man
[Music]
game
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
okay
it's fine
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
convention
um
well well well well well well
cozy
did he thank me for killing him
that sucked
I want you all to know that I hated
every second of that
get out of here Bots you suck
you suck
Bots
Eve yes I have legs
yeah he was the guy he was the
the SK he carved the monks
and he became shura
the battle memory of an extraordinary
foe lingering in the mind of the wolf
commune with the sculptor's idol and
confront memories
the one-armed demon riled the
battlefield consumed by Flames of deep
deepest resentment
I feel like I did that in the hardest
way I could have
which is very on par with me
very on par
I was massively under leveled for Orphan
of cause
Dark Souls 3 we kind of ran through
that was ridiculous
that fight
was
ridiculous
re
ridiculous
there was so much I had to think about
that entire fight
and I kid you not
if I [ __ ] up I die
pretty much
would you say harder than Melania no
Melania is [ __ ]
that boss is just hard
once I learned it
I knew everything that I had to do
and everything was dodgeable everything
was deflectable
everything I could get away from
I could
Melania
honestly isn't that hard
he's really not
melania's only hard because of waterfowl
and she can heal
that's it
that's it
really not that bad
I think her
waterfowl is [ __ ]
I agree jkx
jxk
that was a lot
that put my mind through the ringer
it really did
but now I'm all cozy and I feel better
let's go beat issue
[ __ ] it dude I'm here for it
lapis lazuli that's from Minecraft
right
that's Minecraft
literally Minecraft
what's my Chipotle order I just get a
burrito
with steak
nothing else
just steak
do I have to travel out of this area
did asthma gold play this game
I don't think I ever saw him play this
game but I've seen him play all the
others
I love asthma gold dude
I kid you not I think asthma Gold's
gonna be on YouTube soon
I think he's gonna stream on YouTube
ishin is in the ashina reservoir
right
right
I think I have to travel out of here
yeah I want to play little nightmares
I want to beat the game today
the main thing like I want to beat the
game today because I feel like we're
gonna beat it pretty quick if we just go
tomorrow
you know
up the stairs
oh
bad
lump of Wax
oh
who's this
granny
have you guys not seen little nightmares
before
it's fire so good
[Music]
I think little nightmares 2 is better
than little nightmares one
pretty rare
you haven't you're in for a treat then I
think I'll stream it tomorrow or Monday
what does she want I didn't pay
attention my brain is mush
my brain is mush
yeah that's a good point both games are
really good
little nightmares 2 is a prequel correct
is there anything of value up in here
up in her up in her
oh
well
foreign
there is something up there
I just want to fight ishin guys and go
get Chipotle that's what I want to do
your delaying me right now
I don't know how I feel about it
chat I already got it
'd be something different
yep we're going to Asian
I have to say probably compared to that
boss
you should might be pretty easy actually
ishin's hard as [ __ ] so I don't know
what I'm talking about
ignore me
[Music]
that's what I'm gonna get
I'm gonna drive
to get a steak burrito
it sounds really good
holy titty sprinkles dude
that fight
was crazy
that was on par with the craziness of
Orphan of cause
straight up
that was on par
okay how do I get where I want to go
that should work
at this time of night dog it's 4 P.M
it's four o'clock bro
I know I gotta go to kuro's room I just
don't remember how to actually there
it's almost midnight
oh
I don't live in Ohio
[Music]
I have to go over there right
[Music]
oh
this music going way too hard for me
right now
foreign
way too hard
[Music]
I do not remember having to go this far
look at the Eastern
dude [ __ ] I'm back here
foreign
[Music]
chat I don't live on planet Earth
you're way off
I'm an alien
I just want to fight ishin that's all I
want
where the [ __ ] am I going
hopefully this way
I don't know how to get to the reservoir
man I don't know how I don't know where
I am
I feel like this is the wrong way
[Music]
where does Jake live
doesn't matter
no
I can't travel there
[Music]
I can't
it's this side turn back if you value
your life no
that's what a headless is no
no no no no no no
it's part of a Sheena Castle
I mean I'm here bro
foreign
a house
have you seen the exuberant prices for
houses right now
in the U.S
[Music]
it's ridiculous
I I can't
I just don't know where I am guys I
don't know
get me out
yes
multiple Leviathan class create creates
detected multiple leviathan-class
creatures detected are you sure what you
are doing is worth it
that's another game we should play on
stream
you guys like subnautica
pretty [ __ ] fire
Midwest says cheaper housing
you know what else is really cheap
your mom
not even 50 bucks dude
not even 50 bucks
foreign
[Music]
where am I going
I can't go that way
that looks like death
use the shortcut yes daddy
oh she's a high price tour why was she
25 bucks then
is that high price for her are you poor
okay I'm done I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
sorry
[Laughter]
I know I know I know
I know
okay
where am I going that's where we were
this whole damn time
or is there a place I can travel
foreign
guys are talking about I don't know how
to get there okay
I don't know how what part A Sheena
castle look how I can't go to these
places right here can't go to them
can't go to them
I lost a subscriber [ __ ] why what
happened
am I not in a Sheena Castle right now
I'm going out the I'm going out the
[ __ ] window
all right I'm going I'm going I'm going
no somebody told me in chat that I lost
a subscriber
I think they were kidding
follow the smoke
okay
well I can't get back up there
yeah I'm a Shinobi let me sit down [ __ ]
there's a door dude I'm a poop
I'm a I'm a poop
and you're all gonna be like what the
[ __ ]
what the [ __ ]
damn we've been live seven and a half
hours holy [ __ ]
I don't even know
this music's too intense
guys where's the rest of the Smoky boys
[Music]
foreign
two and a half crazy I think
this don't feel right
I was at the right spot and turned
around oh did that make you mad
when I didn't go to the spot
that you thought I would
did you get mad
when I did that
did you get mad
[Music]
did somebody get mad
oh
I'm going I'm going straight for you
Shin bro I I ain't giving a [ __ ] about
this right here
this game has broke my brain
[Music]
I think I'm becoming sure
I think that's what's happening
I'm okay with it
I kind of like it
I really am succumbing huh
I'm so coming I'm here I'm sure now
[ __ ]
okay this is this Blanket's actually
like too hot
actually too hot
all right let's go
I don't steal anything from chat you
know why because you guys don't really
have anything interesting to say ever
hahaha
canceled
Bring It On
you cut my boy
use your last skill points
is it not dumb that there's just two
mortal blades
is that just dumb
to anybody else
or does it make sense
I always thought it was weird he's like
look another one
why are there two of these things
[Music]
yeah it seems a little too convenient
right
laughs
different purpose okay okay I'm sure
there is actually
I have I have all the confidence in the
world right now
I'm gonna annihilate this loser
the black on his skin looks really cool
though like the they look like tattoos
but I think they're like burn marks or
something I don't know weakness
that's how you use that idiot you use it
like that
Bonk
no you're a loser loser you used it a
weapon that wasn't a sword
it's like using tools imagine
couldn't be me
[Music]
okay
I actually have to pay attention
laughs
oh I'm just like in a mood to make chat
angry because they made me angry during
that entire thingy
you guys were mean I had to tell on you
okay we go again
foreign
[Music]
I need to get rid of this I don't want
to use the Mortal blade
damn it
okay
[Music]
okay this is okay imagine
fighting a literal fire demon for three
hours and then going to something normal
okay
shut your [ __ ] mouth
oh wait
boom
[Music]
okay so he just Powers through that [ __ ]
huh
[Music]
okay okay
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[ __ ]
get it get him out of here
get him out of here trash
even though he killed me first
whatever
I want to say you guys make me this way
it's your fault it's all your fault
I can't possibly do anything wrong
I'm the streamer
foreign
that's fine
now
foreign
kind of the same colors
[Music]
what kind of forearm workouts do you
think he does
[Music]
I forgot that one
River
okay I gotta remember your [ __ ] brother
I don't remember your [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
yeah that's a Dodge that's a dodgeball
right there
[Music]
okay
okay
so
yep
yep
foreign
all right all right
I don't remember what to attack I really
doubt it's bloodborne
he's out here playing bloodborne
thank you
[Music]
oh that's a jumpy boy okay
[Music]
all right
yep that one hurt
that one hurt my soul
I wonder leveled is he levels are there
levels in this game
okay I'm an idiot
okay so that didn't count
I I didn't count at all
there's literally no leveling in this
game you just get skills and you can
upgrade your attack power but that comes
after beating bosses only
so you don't like get levels that you
put into
Vegas well that means it's not a Souls
game
that means it's not a Souls game because
it's not an RPG technically
[Music]
episode
[Music]
[Music]
annihilated
annihilated
[Music]
okay
listen
don't do that
[Music]
that's so [ __ ] cool
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
oh
that hurt my soul and my ego
oh man
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah yep
kill him
dude I am [ __ ] exhausted
have a good one Stan thank you for your
help
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
get out
bad at the game better the game better
the game
[Music]
[Music]
oh
sure
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I got the bot
I got it
off
excellent
okay no doubles
no doubles
[Music]
I'm pretty sure I can jump that right
[Music]
thank you
what are you even doing
[Music]
foreign
bro he is ridiculous
we can do it though we can do it though
we can do it though
bro Jake what the [ __ ] you only
restarted playing this one or two days
ago and you got way far in the story
I've been playing for almost two to
three weeks
yeah dude get [ __ ] I mean
yeah
yep
no I don't know
I'm just so hungry
foreign
[Music]
bye bye
bye bye
okay yeah he just dove into that [ __ ]
bro okay
[Music]
excellent
[Music]
um I stepped to the side
not enough though
not enough to decide
not even close
just the fact that I have to fight
kanichiro at the beginning every time
makes this fight very
annoying
hesitation is defeat
all right chat
hesitation be defeat
[Music]
whatevs whatevs
[Music]
[Music]
sure
[Music]
Rock
ETS
foreign
[Music]
jump that next time
very smooth fight
very smooth
good [ __ ]
no
take you off
[Music]
[Music]
no way
one hit huh that's all it took
I know you can jump that [ __ ] you just
have to do it at the perfect time damn
it
okay that was really good though
really good
can I just jump on his head
I thought you had to jump at the perfect
time or whatever
[Music]
hi fiction
[Music]
come on
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
double jump on his head okay I'll eat it
[Music]
his moveset is so sick
dude stop
[Music]
not a friendly second first stage
[Music]
I literally just [ __ ] up that's it
I kept trying to heal and he just kept
getting in my face like
he's playing me perfectly right now
[Music]
okay that's weird
all right I mean he just played me like
a fiddle just now
like a fiddle
I got absolutely dumpstered on just now
it hurt
it hurt
the fact we're already getting to stage
two of Geisha or ishin is really good
foreign
[Music]
all right Jen
why is that so big the [ __ ]
[Music]
happened
[Music]
what is happening I was pairing that
just fine like first few tries and now I
can't do it
oh man I don't know what's happening to
me right now
I legit can't see his attacks right now
this is weird
three two
I think I do need food
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh Shake It Off
no
[ __ ] way dude
[Music]
thank you Rocco
hold on man I gotta Focus thank you dude
why am I doing that
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
popping off popping off dude let's go
let's go bro
[Music]
where are you going what the heck
come on
foreign
[Music]
easy game
easy game
oh you're my
um
do it
suitable
boom
Rocco thank you again for the 10.33
Super Chat I really appreciate that
thank you
thank you thank you double jump a little
late on the spinning attack besides that
nice work good videos too thank you I
did the double jump it worked thank you
thank you thank you
Gauntlet of strength nice
right now what
okay so our boy is dead here
did we just do that
we already beat father we beat father Al
forever ago bro Oh you mean the other
owl
guys please I've been streaming eight
hours please dude I can't
okay I'm just gonna hit our boy Kuro
here
oh there's multiple endings but I think
we only have the option for one yeah we
do
we're just gonna do this one
maybe we'll come back to a new game plus
and we'll do all the other ones
do you know namita
oh God
you know how hard that would be
[Music]
um
bruh
rip
this is so cool
a vicious cycle you could say
there's Emma
Korea
yeah
it is kind of a bad ending
no doubt the day will come when in a
snowy arrives seeking strength
wouldn't this suggests sakuro 2 or is it
just the Vicious Cycle that they're
referring to
first time I saw that I was like sakiro
too yeah
no word on it at all
there you go guys
there you go
Gotta Die Twice yeah I think it is just
the cycle all right
great game love it
[Music]
I think I like bloodborne a bit more
I think I like Dark Souls 3 a bit more
just because that was my first
[Music]
but what a great [ __ ] game man
guess I'm a little late to stream I
started eight hours ago
all right guys
so tomorrow
we are gonna start little nightmares
if you haven't played little nightmares
or thinking about it tune into that
stream absolutely it's kind of like some
other games some other horror game type
stuff you know I'm saying
that I think would be fun for the month
of October
tomorrow probably later in the day like
I probably won't be starting the stream
until around now if that makes sense
um I need to I have stuff that I need to
do during the day tomorrow so we're
gonna have a later stream tomorrow and
we're going to play little nightmares
and I think the next day we can beat
little nightmares in one stream I almost
can guarantee it and then we'll play
little nightmares 2 the next day so
really like some of my favorite games of
all time are little nightmares one and
two so
come by if you want to see it other than
that
I'm out of here is scorn coming out next
week I might play that maybe maybe we'll
see
we'll see Priscilla thank you thank you
I appreciate it I know I I mostly stream
now I I have not had the urge to make uh
videos lately I just haven't I've been
enjoying streaming a lot so I'm just
gonna do what I like doing and then if I
have a a video idea that I'm really
looking forward to then
we'll get on that but streaming is
definitely the thing I like more
so
I'm out here dude
peace have a great rest of your day and
we'll be back tomorrow evening starting
around whatever time it is for you right
now probably around 5 PM CSD so
bye guys
have a good one bye bye bye bye bye bye